escenas como estas se han convertido en
lo cotidiano en la clínica del doctor
mario north ja
el pil no se puede dar el lujo de perder
pacientes con la crisis económica la
super infracción y la crisis energética
este dentista ha perdido el 70 por
ciento de sus ingresos ahora trabaja
solo porque no pudo pagar al personal en
ningún otro lugar estamos trabajando de
manera tan precaria no podemos cobrar a
los pacientes en dólares pero compramos
todo el material clínico en dólares y
sólo podemos trabajar en las horas con
electricidad por lo que tenemos menos
pacientes donar
cada vez es más difícil encontrar
especialistas en el líbano muchos ganan
al mes menos de 150 dólares la doctora
lina trabaja en tres hospitales y tiene
una consulta privada pero aún así no es
suficiente para mantenerse no puedo
subir les las tarifas a los padres de
mis pacientes todo el mundo está aquí
atravesando fuertes dificultades
económicas mis hijos están estudiando en
la universidad y no querríamos irnos
pero el futuro es muy oscuro marilina
forman parte de ese grupo de médicos que
todavía resisten en el líbano mientras
un 40 por ciento de sus colegas ha
optado por emigrar a otros países el
éxodo de médicos ha obligado a los
hospitales privados a tener que reducir
o cerrar servicios lo que representa una
amenaza para población en tiempos de
pandemia
el sector salud se ha visto muy afectado
con la migración de médicos por la
crisis económica estamos corriendo un
alto riesgo con el joven 19 la capacidad
de los hospitales se ha reducido a un
40% y tenemos muchas dificultades
logísticas
el líbano ha sido reconocido durante
décadas como el hospital de medio
oriente por sus tecnologías y
especialistas pero ahora quedan pocos
médicos que apuestan por un futuro sin
profesionales que lo sustente el sistema
de salud libanés será una víctima más de
las múltiples crisis que afronta el país